people find it remarkable that chat gbd
can do logic well how did Aristotle come
up with logic well he looked at a bunch
of I mean we don't know really but sort
of a model for it would be looked at a
bunch of examples of rhetoric a bunch of
arguments that people had made and said
oh there were these patterns in the
arguments people made those patterns are
syllogistic logic those are these
particular forms of syllogism that where
one thing is deduced from another and
that's what chat GPT is seeing in lots
of the texts that it finds on the web
it's seeing essentially syllogisms um
because it sees when you get this and
this and this it gives this and so it
sort of discovers syllogistic logic